you want to be a copywriter in 2025 well
you need to forget everything that you
read on Twitter listen I made over six
figures writing copy in 2024 and if I
had to start from zero this is the exact
stepbystep framework that I would use to
make it all back again and I'm going to
give it to you for free in today's video
what's going on everybody Allan dragu L
copygo here another gem for you today
with today's video and if you are a copy
wrer before we dive in I've got a free
gift for you in the link in the
description below I have a free
copyrighting guide called copyrighting
Catalyst some of my most profitable and
wise copyrighting tips I've jam-packed
into one easyto read guide that you can
dive into instantly all you got to do is
click the link in the description below
give me your email tell me where to send
it and I'll give it to you today instant
no problem now that I've already given
you some free stuff some free wisdom to
help you on your copyrighting journey
let's start with the step St by-step
framework to get you going no fluff
let's dive in starting with phase zero
before you start diving in and getting
clients and all this stuff we need to
build a plan okay I'm a structured kind
of guy and once we have a plan we know
what to tackle how to tackle it and why
to tackle it and that's exactly what
makes up our plan our why what and how
we need to know why we're doing what
we're doing what we're going to do to
get there and how we're going to do it
broken down in that I stole that from
Simon syndic it has guided every single
business business I've built for the
last 10 years starting with why the
copyrighting framework that I build for
my why is autonomy freedom and joy I
want to be able to make the decision of
when I work how I work who I work with
and copyrighting is the perfect fit for
that style of autonomy I get to pick my
clients really wisely get to make a good
bit of money off those clients and I get
to enjoy the art of writing if you are a
writer like me I want to enjoy my work
and you want to enjoy your work too and
so having a strong why will keep you
going throughout the year but I would
take a couple minutes and say why
copyrighting why 2025 why six figures
the what is simple what do you want to
accomplish well the what to me is I want
to make $10,000 per month writing copy
okay you see that number thrown around
but it's a good number because it's a
simple number and it's plenty of money
that's
$120,000 per year okay you take some
taxes out of that you're probably
getting 90k 85k you're making a good
living writing copy with not a ton of
work pick a number that works for you
depending on the country you live in
depending on your family the size of
your family whatever it is let's go with
10K for right now that's the what now
let's go with the how the how to do that
I keep it really simple okay I focus on
the things that I can control okay I
can't control making 10K a month but I
can control showing up and writing copy
every day okay or showing up and reading
an ad every single day so I really focus
on how via the controllables which I
think you should as well starting with
building a daily copyrighting routine
okay I made a totally separate video on
this where I break down my 2our per day
daily copyrighting routine and I will
make sure to link it up there and put it
in the description so you can see
exactly my 2hour daily copyrighting
routine so you can get good really fast
the other one is how we're going to get
there is I'm going to pick a very
profitable sector of copyrighting okay
like in 2025 you know what I'm not
writing copy for is I'm not writing copy
for social media or blogs or content or
anything like that because AI has swept
that stuff under the rug and you could
get barely paid for those not to mention
that's more like content writing not
copyrighting so for 2025 I'm picking one
of these three and it's writing ads like
meta ads Tik Tok ads Facebook ads
Instagram ads emails because you can
track clicks opens sales very trackable
very profitable or I would write sales
landing pages where you can increase the
conversion rates and truly track sales
all three of those tie directly to
metrics that make them your clients or
you more money now for the sake of
generalities here where most YouTube
videos give you generalities and they're
just like oh yeah here's what I would
potentially do no here's exactly what I
would do I would pick emails I would
focus on eCommerce Brands and I would
work for clients which slightly goes
backwards to what I would say typically
I'm a big fan of building your own email
list writing your own emails for
yourself and selling your own products
but that's a long-term play so if I
wanted to make six figures in 2025 and
get to 10,000 a month as fast as
possible I'm not building my own email
list that's that's for longterm I am
focusing on email High highly profitable
really good skill set and eCommerce
Brands okay so I'm going to use that to
guide the rest of the video on the
practices that we're going to do if you
want to go a different direction it's
not a big deal this step by step will
still work for you but I'm going to use
that as a pure example of exactly what I
would do no fluff next step after Step
Zero with the plan is step one and that
is learn the fundamentals okay if I'm
starting from zero I'm assuming you know
nothing about copyrighting all right if
I know nothing about copywriting I'm
immediately picking up two resources
Kick-Ass copywriting by John Carlton and
cash vertising by Drew Eric Whitman okay
those two resources alone are going to
cost you about 75 bucks 50 bucks for KI
ass copyrighting and about 15 bucks for
cashvertising okay between those two you
should fully understand the fundamentals
of copywriting human psychology emotion
persuasion Frameworks all of those
things tips and tricks Simplicity words
values propositions all of those things
you're going to master those by reading
those books okay go grab those and read
them two times each all right that's the
first and the fastest thing that you
should do is you have to understand the
fundamentals of copywriting before you
could guess what write copy step two is
now that you understand the fundamentals
of copywriting you need to build your
portfolio if it were me I'm going to
list five dream brands that I would love
to work with Brands like Omega ag1
walrus audio New Balance free Rite I
mean whatever just list brands that you
would love working with and start
writing emails for those Brands this is
called spec work because they didn't
technically hire you to do the work but
you can't just let all that new fun
mental knowledge float around in your
head doing nothing with it you need to
start putting it to work and so the best
way to do that is if you were going to
write for these Brands what would you
write for them go ahead and write those
emails and use it to build your
portfolio I would aim to write one to
three emails a day shoot for about a
thousand words okay every day you show
up and you're going to write a th Words
which ends up to one to three emails for
those Brands build up your portfolio in
a couple weeks you're going to have 15
to 20 emails no problem the Trap here is
that most people commit to like writing
a tweet a day or writing a thread a day
don't do that you need to practice the
exact skill set you're trying to sell
emails okay for me it's emails or ads or
whatever just write the spec workk build
a massive portfolio forget all that
social stuff we're looking for cash not
likes and followers okay step number
three is now that you have a portfolio
you need to do free work okay this is
fantastic for gaining experience and
actually putting your skill set to use
you need to text friends family people
on social media and show them hey here's
my portfolio I've written emails like
this do you need some help with your
e-commerce brand okay I know you have a
network of friends or families that
could definitely benefit from your skill
set okay even if it's just people on
Twitter that launch their sunglasses
e-commerce brain and they don't have
anybody doing it offer to do it for free
this is going to give you the
opportunity to learn what it looks like
to work with a client and to get results
which leads us to step number four you
need to build a case study okay now that
you've done some work for free you need
to look at the work that you did and
look at the transformation okay before
you so and so got x amount of cash from
these emails after you that same brand
got this much more cash from these
emails and open rates and click rates
and case stud all this stuff take
everything you did in the transformation
you built for that brand and document it
in your portfolio this builds proof that
you are good at what you do and that
proof is going to enable you to get
paying clients which leads us to step
five get a paying client here are three
ways for you to get a paying client one
ask your current free client if they
would like to pay you for more work
especially using the proof that you just
got hey thank you so much for giving me
the opportunity would you consider
paying me a small fee of x amount to do
emails for you on a regular basis since
we got such great results a lot of
people since they're making money off
your emails will say hey yeah that's
awesome thank you so much number two if
they don't want to do that you can ask
them for a referral hey thanks so much
for giving me the opportunity to write
these emails do you know one person just
like you that has an Ecom brand that
could use my help based on the great
results we got for you I can go help
them do you know one person don't ask
for 10 referrals ask for one person okay
or number three is the network with your
people friends family social media
showing the proof you just got post your
case study on Twitter on Reddit in
Facebook groups okay text your friends
and family these other people that might
have Ecom brands that might know
somebody with an Ecom brand and show
them the proof hey John I just did X for
Joe over here and I got him some killer
results do you know anybody that could
use my help to make more money with
email now you're starting to get some
leads some serious people here's how to
charge those people I would personally
start with about $2500 a month for three
emails a week depending on the brand
make sure the brand has at least a
million dollar in annual recurring
Revenue meaning for a m they make a
million dollars a year as a brand you
can find these statistics in their clavo
which is their email service provider a
million a year is about $888,000 a month
if they're making $888,000 a month it
should be no problem to hire you for
about $2,500 a month to directly impact
that revenue and grow it I would commit
to about three emails a week plus
unlimited revisions and unlimited access
to me remember you are building this for
the first time so you need to take the
edge out of agencies agencies can
provide all this fancy stuff but you
could say hey I'm your guy you could
reach out to me anytime call me text me
I'm not going to send you to some Joo
landing page or AI Bots to respond to
your questions I'm going to answer you
I'm going to be your go-to guy and it's
only going to cost you a fraction of all
the cash I'm going to make you with just
four clients at $2,500 a month we hit
our $110,000 a month which leads us to
step number six ruthlessly reach out
getting clients is simply a number
numbers game the more you reach out to
people and show them your emails in
proof the more likely you will get paid
and remember we only need four that's it
so if you reach out to five people a day
that's 25 people Monday through Friday
that's taking weekends off that means
you've reached out to a 100 people at
the end of the month and all you need to
do is lock in four you do that for one
two three months and I guarantee you've
locked in four clients it's hustle and
you can make 10K in a minimum of 3 to
maybe 6 months here's my secret sauce of
where to find those people I would go on
indeed or monster.com or zip recruiter
and I'm starting to type in things like
email specialist email marketer
copywriter marketing specialist whatever
and I'm reading those job descriptions
and I'm going to toss my hat in for
those applications and let them know hey
here's the proof here's what I can do
are you guys with willing to look at a
remote employee right a contract you
don't have to pay my health insurance my
benefits you don't have to pay my laptop
you don't have to pay any of that stuff
and when you start saying stuff like
that these companies are like ooh that's
pretty attractive and so now you're
reaching out on the regular you can even
turn on notifications for indeed and
monster and all those sites to start
emailing you job listings for you to
knock out your five outreaches per day
so at this point you've even got
Outreach automated I would stay away
from the cold DMS that's just a really
tough game at this point you want to
look for people who are already looking
for you they just haven't found you so
those job posting sites are perfect at
this point we're 3 to 6 months in and
you've got 10K going and you've got a
lot to learn about satisfying customer
service taking care of your clients
writing great emails and making money
but you've hit your 10K a month Mark and
the next step after this is going Beyond
10K a month now that you've got the
email thing down I would focus on
upselling your current clients offer to
write their ads and their landing pages
so now you got their emails their ads
their landing pages you can even offer
to write their SMS text for Ecom Brands
and start charging more add an extra
th000 an extra 2,000 to your services
and now you've got clients that are
paying you 3 4 5K a hit and you're
making 15K a month and listen it's not
easy it is simple but it's not easy this
takes a tremendous amount of of work I
guarantee though within 3 to 6 months
you're living a fantastic Dream Life as
a copywriter that you can truly enjoy
and make a great sum of cash but that's
it that wraps us up those are my faces
that if I were to start over from ground
Zer today those are the exact steps that
me L copy goat would do to get back to
100K plus no fluff no lies that's my
road map and if you found this video
valuable it would mean the world to me
if you could like And subscribe to the
channel and I will keep pumping out
valuable free content just like this for
you and don't forget before you head out
I gave you that gift at the beginning
hit the link in the description below
get that gift and start learning
copyrighting today appreciate it and I
will catch you on the next
one valuable gems I tell you valuable
gems mhm did you hit subscribe you
didn't hit subscribe are you serious why
are you here did you not just I give you
all that free content you didn't hit
subscribe you you need to smash smash It
smash
subscribe smash it
yes thank you for doing that I
appreciate it
[Music]